okay go to Google and you look up the
history what the hi here we go swim hi
mom
my daughter we're about to go into my
search history so Adam can see things
about me that he that might not know I'm
gonna take this opportunity and I'm just
gonna go with it read anything I don't
care this is not that exciting dead you
you Google some pretty weird [ __ ] new
hair salons near me elbow clicks when I
bench press when you get to a certain
age your joints start to click it's just
normal for people my age how to keep
calm map of USA they running away yes I
tried take me with you it I'm looking at
I see a handbag oh that Wow a two
thousand dollar handbag we're just
looking at it we weren't doing anything
the with it cute though right and read
you watching some Netflix are you
chilling that was yeah interesting sex
hair for you oh yeah sexy hairstyles to
impress your husbands
how long can I cast and I was working on
a new look oh I'm working on a new look
oh my Graham I'm working on a new look
honey hello oh my god our AC went out
during the 114 degree heat wave
scooby-doo's and I was really worried
that the cat might not survive so how
long can it last what I won't get a cat
last anything else you'd like to the
great okay Roger I was right I wanted to
know don't judge me
I mean you better be glad I am still
sexy hello just as I suspected your
search history is just as boring as you
are I'm boring I'm a nerd what do you
want from me get the best body of your
life new $1 trial for 30 days
oh yeah there's a bodybuilder let's get
fit together.we clinic what wait what is
this wait but we've maps oh oh my god
Wow Wow
wait first of all and you were just
getting on man first of all and your way
out oh my god
Oh pain how to murder your wife that has
nothing to discuss on how to murder your
wife has nothing swith Jack Lemmon what
are you watching Jack Lemmon stars in
this boom ha to murder your wife is what
you're watching just mom no okay okay
I didn't even download that on purpose
it's not a download you searched it like
you literally typed in weed maps calm
how her this is a new thing I was just
trying to figure it out that's a great
movie I've ever seen it Oh what do you -
it's a movie have a murder your wife
it's a comedy I didn't decide that my
friend starts you remember Kim from you
know over there when we that was create
an interval she Google mother I deleted
it of course because I didn't want you
to get in my phone I didn't want nobody
to see it have you even ever smoked weed
before like you dude I have to say our
back okay in front of these people my
mother still my mother yes always the
search history was fun luckily with that
talker it'll never have it again
not to get my phone I love her I don't
really need Google cuz I have him
history books I'm here
[Music]